[Music]
the Berlin Allah is one of the most
important international film festivals
and attracts attention all over the
world the festival program presents over
400 films on wasn't 60 different screens
and a total of over 2,500 screenings the
logistics required to handle this huge
amount of screenings completely changed
as film production and distribution has
moved into the digital era during the
last couple of years or whole process
became digital we now and store all the
films that we receive for the festival
and also for the European film market on
one huge one petabyte server as many of
the films that we receive are just
finished last minute it is very
important for us to get them to the film
office in Berlin as soon as possible and
aspera enables us to receive those films
quickly and efficiently over the
internet and then we send about 250
films every day to the different venues
that we use
aspera is a data transfer technology
which is used around the world
significantly in the film industry to
transfer large amounts of data at large
international distances at very high
speeds often maybe a hundred times
faster than conventional technologies at
the core of the technology there's a
newly invented transport layer it runs
on top of a basic diagram service which
is UDP aspera fast protocol implements
its own congestion control mechanism its
own reliability mechanisms and it's
designed from the ground up for bulk
data transfer speeds independent of
network conditions and network this
[Music]
together with your asperity we were able
to integrate the digital delivery of
films into or existing highly automated
QC and distribution processes we use the
espera Conville to track all the
incoming suspects transfers and then use
the orchestrator to analyze and manage
all the incoming packages and
automatically send them to our internal
API
the use case of the Bernalillo festival
is perfect for experiment they use large
content in DCP and QuickTime format
content comes from all around the world
in international distances and most
importantly needs to be here in time
there's an avenue for us to promote some
of the newer technologies we've been
working on a lot of new things around
the streaming area along different
faster transfers around automation and
we're looking forward to introducing and
providing this technology to the Berlin
our engineering team in the years to
come
[Music]
you